concentré ces étudiants en première
année d'étude de santé révisent avant
leur concours toute l'année ils ont
suivi leurs cours ici en visioconférence
alors que les enseignants étaient à
Dijon pas de quoi les inquiéter bien au
contraire pour beaucoup les conditions
étaient optimales vu la charge de
travail j'habite à 15 minutes de d'ici
en voiture donc c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour la logistique et tout pas
besoin d'avoir un une chambre d'étudiant
à Dijon c'est moins cher
ça permet de rester chez mes parents du
coup c'est plus facile pour me
concentrer sur les cours parce que ben
en fait je fais les cours et puis je
rentre et puis tout est prêt donc j'ai
rien d'autre à faire si les formations
se sont multipliées à Nevers ces
dernières années certaines sont bien
implantées et attirent des jeunes de
toute la France c'est le cas de l'ISAT
d'où sortent des ingénieurs spécialisés
dans l'automobile et les transports mais
aussi de les sabs chaque année 205
étudiantes s'y forment au design où se
prépare à intégrer les les plus
prestigieuses j'ai vu qu'il y avait du
coup cette école sur Nevers qui avait
une spécialité au niveau des dnmates qui
étaient assez large qui était pas
justement trop spécialisé donc du coup
ça m'intéressait c'est une école
importante avec avec une classe
préparatoire
DNA de qui vous gratte de licence et
puis un DSA qui équivaut un grade de
master donc nous avons toute la panoplie
de bac + 2 à bac + 5 au sein de notre
établissement avec beaucoup de demandes
chaque année sur la plateforme parcours
sup une offre qui permet à de plus en
plus de jeunes de poursuivre leurs
études ici et de favoriser les
implantations à long terme car pour
beaucoup il y a des débouchés dans la
Nièvre comme pour les étudiants du but
informatique la dernière formation à
avoir ouvert ses portes à Nevers il y a
deux ans et demi il y a beaucoup
d'acteurs locaux notamment
l'agglomération est beaucoup
d'entreprises informatiques
qui qui anticipé cette formation parce
qu'ils vont avoir des besoins de
développement et donc ça permet à des
jeunes aussi de rester dans leur région
d'origine aujourd'hui Nevers attire
chaque année plus de 3000 étudiants ce
qui en fait la deuxième ville
universitaire en Bourgogne après Dijon